sometimes I want to fall in the show and
spit in buckets and go you not all
[ __ ] up
hey what's going on everybody first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hide her wings and
today's episode is brought to you by
legend of soul guard it's a reunion
special with the human Panda Eddie Wang
Chao Stu soulguard he's a food media
powerhouse chef restaurateur and
best-selling author and he has a new
show on the way cash-only where Eddie
explores immigrant owned restaurants and
kitchens around the world Eddie Wong
welcome back to hot ones thank you for
having me it's good to have you back my
[ __ ] is already scared the question
on everyone's mind
are you starting wing ten first this
time out not because I'm also gonna
stand I have a whole I have a whole
strategy standing as part of it all
right okay last time I did this what I
realized is when you go ten first then
the rest of the show you're burning
right if you go this way you could talk
you can interview and then by the time
you get here you're just out you go
straight home to the bathroom to the
shower whatever you need to do with your
life well it's good that you learn
something and you know it's one of the
most talked about hot ones moments in
history do hot ones fans ever approached
you on the street and talked to you
about it yeah do you people people
frequently like oh I saw you burn your
dick like it is pretty amazing all right
Eddie are you ready for round two yes I
also have one I'm gonna switch with you
because I have a whole have a sneaking
suspicion you know but also just for the
fans to know you know like that is
actually hot or not hot all right well
let's put that to the test always have a
strategy
[Music]
you'll have like double hot sauce on
yours
you know there's no turning back now all
right we've sitting back yeah we
switched this first one is the howler
monkey I'm fine see where you are we're
still French so last time you and I
appeared on camera you beat my ass over
at overthrow a boxing club I know that
you and Edgar have been training hard
good what's a piece of self-defense
advice that you'd give to someone with
zero fight experience run running is
very useful but even like even if I spar
like I sparred Edgar this morning like I
always try to like run and like fight on
the run so I think I think learning to
throw jabs learning to throw your
straight on the run is a good technique
and then I know that your other favorite
weekend where your activity is playing
pick-up basketball do you have any pick
up pet peeves yes the lawyers League
guys look like after work corporate dude
those dudes always the worst to play
with it's like Facebook took a dump
today so I'm gonna [ __ ] elbow you in
the ribs you know and then I know that
you're a Knicks diehard yeah if you were
GM what would be your first order of
business to return the team to greatness
shouts to the Knicks
I love the Knicks they give me these
tickets I get to go eat in this week
honestly I have thought about killing
James Dolan like you they have very
sharp steak knives and I'm like look for
the Knicks we might have to do this like
I think that the best thing to do would
be to kill James Dolan that that one you
get some heat you're like all right
towards the back you get a little bit of
heat also a very important thing on how
one's is to remember which side of the
napkin you like rubbed your fingers on
because you start to get excited and you
rub hot sauce in your eye son your new
show cash only focused on the kitchens
of immigrants throughout the world and
it seems like you're really carrying the
torch from Bourdain to use food as a
tool to open up some bigger issues I see
this chasm because if you are from a
certain lower segment Sochi
economically in society and you come up
with a great idea like you're gonna get
absorbed by somebody if you get lucky
you'll get bought by somebody but most
likely somebody is gonna take your [ __ ]
and make it theirs
somebody will absorb it onto like a
square plate with drizzle or absorb it
into a salad absorb it into a smoothie
absorb it into some like white box
restaurant in Soho or the West Village
you know like that's where everything
goes to die so I want to go to these
countries and take the local route like
I always have go to the cash-only
restaurants I think the more that
Americans with power or even like
Chinese people with power or anybody
Germans with money and powers see it
they're gonna be like hey I don't need
the like comfortable co-opted
appropriated sterilized version of this
I want the like real yo yo I want the
real version I'm gonna go support that
guy you recently tweeted your disapprove
of a new Gordon Ramsay show or it sounds
like he'll be dropping into foreign
countries to show the locals that he can
cook their cuisines better than they can
what annoys you about that number one
why do you need to go show people like
you you're better than them or to like
continue to impose that traveling is
about meeting people and hearing them
out and listening to what they have to
say
and I think to like go in somewhere and
be like I'm gonna beat you in your own
house doing your own dish it's just like
that's not the point of food i man it
just starts to get spicy
so from Long's world to cash-only you've
not been doing destination TV for eight
years strong so I'm hoping that I can
lean on you for some travel
recommendations where would you suggest
I go for a romantic getaway you know I
had this I had this book before Kanye
went but like Wyoming is actually
amazing for like fly fishing hiking I
would go do that it's interesting to see
that part of America the frontiersman
West how about a lads holiday or a
bachelor party on a budget
I mean Tijuana is like it is an older
bachelor party destination but the Hong
Kong strip club is probably the most
insane strip club ever so Tijuana you go
to Hong Kong I like the VAM Piro tacos
they're like hard shell vampiro tacos
Tijuana's kind of slept on and it's kind
of back I found Tijuana interesting best
food city in America period all right
I'm gonna give you a curveball I'm gonna
say best food city in North America is
probably Toronto
I think Toronto and LA are neck-and-neck
I like Toronto because you get a lot of
the things you would get in LA but you
get Caribbean food as well but and I let
you you get the Mexican food and then
also the Japanese food in LA is pretty
unstoppable so I would say LA and
Toronto
[Music]
always good to see you
I never that happy to see these wings
this one tastes good
so some of the best conversations I
think we've haven't been off camera
whether we're trading notes about shows
we're talking about the art of an
on-camera interview do you have any
advice for how to put on a good
listening face cuz I feel like mine
looks like Jeffrey Dahmer's mugshot
yours I I didn't have a great listening
face cuz I get so excited especially
right interviewing and somebody says
something cool and Spike Jonze was the
one he said Eddie I love everything you
did walls world Season one I got one
note I was like what he goes you need a
listening face and I was like what the
[ __ ] a listening face he's like it's
just like the eye contact it's a little
breathing and interesting yeah and
whatever you're thinking I try not to
like run down the road with the thought
like hold the thought hold the thought
let the person finish give them a beat
really process oh that one got a little
spicy because I ate mmm
yeah hmm hit that almond milk it's that
time so this next one is the lowest
calientes so hot ones for praia teri hot
sauce
these wings really taste a lot better
thank you for noticing Eddie we really
worked hard to turn that one around you
know all right Eddie will we have
recurring segments on our show called
explain that Graham where you do a deep
dive and I guess Instagram put
interesting pictures that need more
contacts okay so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture and
then you tell me the bigger story all
right sound good
yo all right laptop please it's just
going well for you I'm curious because
last time we were eating it felt so
energetic because I was dying I'm having
a great time all right is your
appearance on bangbus still the IMDB
credit you're most proud of yeah Moe the
hot ones and and bangbus are the ones
that people shadow really yeah and the
funniest thing I'm gonna have to put him
on blast but I remember when this
episode came out and I get a text from
DJ Sol and he's like yo fam I'm watching
Bang Bus are you on the Bang Bus right
now I'm like yes it is but I'm like are
your pants down texting me so when
people text you like you I'm watching
Bang Bus and you're on it I'm like
you're jerking off mid jerk off text in
your man's I was like that's kind of
sauce what were your expectations going
into that shoot and then what was the
reality it actually ended up being
pretty close to what I thought cuz I've
studied her work there hit very closely
and intensely it's like me with food
like I do so much food the food is your
work thing so I don't fetishize food as
much like I see people and oh my god and
it's like dog it's food you know like
you're on the Bang Bus I'm like oh [ __ ]
there's lobster sauce everywhere and
they're like it's it's sperm it's just
it's sperm gets [ __ ] wet wipes you
know it's cool to demystify sex cause
it's like so [ __ ] taboo and [ __ ]
[Music]
they switched the where's a big leap
from that one in this one I will say
Sean's wings are hot it's not a game to
his eating hot ones so I don't get too
heavy while we battle the wings of death
but it's worth noting that the food
world's lost two legends recently and
Anthony Bourdain and Jonathan gold two
guys that I know were very special to
you yeah they were people's chance they
were both white dudes who wanted to know
the real thing they wanted to know the
truth and they would go into
neighborhoods they would explore they
would learn about it and they would
bring the like message in the culture
back in many ways they were Marco Polo I
was real tight with Tony I mean I always
called him uncle and he he always looked
out for me man
he would always like yo don't suck the
dick don't suck the dick he's like once
you start sucking - dick you suck all
the dicks don't suck the dick and I was
like all right cool
but like he was trying to say is like
just be you and if some of the best
advice I ever got one of the best
friends I made he was a real like
amazing mentor for me and a lot of other
people but I think his spirit will
always live on he had such an impact
like the way we talked about hunter s
Thompson now I think he didn't be
talking about 20 Bourdain for a hundred
years
it's not spicy on the front of the
tongue or initially which scares me cuz
I'm like this might be the one that hits
you in the stomach and just drops
through your [ __ ] you know and it is
it's it's a slow oh yeah yeah that one
that one goes through the back of the
tongue throw it down the chest like
that's the old granddad joy woo creeping
back up on you [ __ ]
so you recently started a social media
movement that I think deserves more
shine it's the crazy frugal Asians
hashtag yeah yeah crazy frugal Asian is
the art of taking napkins all right
this is very yes we are frugality is the
way can you hit us with some frugality
hacks does mama Wong have any tips of
the trade well Starbucks and Chipotle
are like a treasure trove oh no and we
always try to take like stuff from like
the bigger corporate businesses you know
I mean the napkins at Starbucks they're
like all the extra sauces in Chipotle
they're not very good but you take them
oh the addition hotels always have la la
Bow so when someone else is paying like
whether it's complex paying or something
I always try to have people pay for me
to stay in a hotel with great like soaps
and shampoos and I will just take them
out of the carts and when the
housekeeping is not looking I take the
whole box I looked online I combine the
fluid ounce weight it was about like
three hundred and fifty dollars of free
la la Bow Wow yeah yeah that's frugality
is the wave
you're their dowels are the front
you two [ __ ] that the bomb one
is where it gets really bad so long
before you were a celebrity chef I know
that you moonlit as a street wear
designer and even engineered a pair of
adidas superstar specifically for cooks
in the kitchen so what I want to do is
bounce some of the most iconic chef fits
off of you and I'm just wondering where
you stand that's a new technique oh gosh
the mouth with the bad and ugly when it
comes to food and fashion does that
sound good
laptop please haven't flashbacks Eddie
he's on his feet look bad
what do you think of the Guy Fieri style
I fought with fire I've been aware of
fire crocs everywhere I actually fought
with everything guys sharing like
everything he's got a dumb ass but I
love him like what about salt bay salt
Bay's incredible I love salt they saw
bass still like he just dressed like
he's at tau 2001 all the time I [ __ ]
love it
he's a really light guy in his
restaurants good - you met him yeah
can't speak English not that that's bad
it's just like you can't communicate
with him you have to just like you know
Eddie Wong Brooke dis dis man could be a
husky member of TLC
he could be redoing the tile in your
home he could be a plumber like could be
a human panda like I I think you kind of
gotta [ __ ] with this checks a lot of box
a lot of [ __ ] boxes how you feel my
man this the bomb [ __ ] is what what the
[ __ ] is this harvested from the walls hi
how are you okay sometimes I want to
fall in the show and spit in buckets and
go crazy you know all [ __ ] up I mean
look at all the sweat on this I always
want to do stuff like that what this
looks at the kool-aid man all right
Eddie I think also just rub snot on him
Thanks I got another nappy thank you
this is legend of saule guard hot sauce
made exclusively for this episode like
the game it's got an interesting fired
ice thing going on so it's got Carolina
Reaper for the heat but it's cooled down
with watermelon and mint the mobile game
is available to download now this will
be my first time trying this hot sauce
some experience in it for the very first
time you get the shakes from the bomb
the bomb is the worst right along with
you
this is
[Music]
so as a jack of many trades and someone
with a knack for stirring the pot you've
attracted a lot of media attention over
the years so what I want to do is take a
couple pull quotes from Eddie Wong
profiles and I'm wondering if you know
where they're from and I'm curious a
reaction to each does that sound good
all right so this first one a walking
mixtape of postmodern cultural
appropriation see I didn't like that and
I remember the dude Joshua David Stein
that wrote a gang bang bang yeah because
he like he didn't understand like how
appropriation actually works it's no
paradox that Wong's brazen attitude
resembles nothing so much as that of his
brash immigrant mother Oh Wesley school
I like Wesley but let me read what he
said it's the third one down I can't
understand cuz there's too many big
words in like I'm so [ __ ] I don't know
what it means one more for ya and he's
smart he's funny he's fast and that's
not an enemy you want to have Tony Tony
huh I remember as Tony
I agree with him I in my second book the
dedication quote was prodigy and it was
like the next rhyme my right might be
about you
I always got picked on when I was a kid
people were always [ __ ] with me and
my dad was always like look dude
somebody steps you gotta hit him real
hard make sure they don't come back well
I'll tell you one thing Eddie I don't
want that smoke all right Eddie so this
is the last Debra ducks
we call it the last dab because as you
know it's tradition around yellow extra
on the last wing you don't have to if
you don't want to but the bottle it's
already turned over here it is it is
happening showing you there's two dad
cheers my man
we made it
I hate to hopper
the bomb is like getting punched in your
stomach that one is like being punching
your face it's like sharper it's like a
hi-hat but yeah it's like in your eyes
this one it's like your whole stomach
coming at you from all angles Eddy in
here we are at the final boss on the hot
ones gauntlet palms sweaty IBS flaring
up and just one more hurdle to jump as
we've touched on already you famously
ran the hot ones gauntlet in Reverse
starting at Number ten last time it
stopped you dead in your tracks and one
of the great hot ones fan debates is
whether or not Eddie Wong belongs on the
Wall of shame as an organization we've
taken a lot of heat protecting you but
I'm curious what's your message to those
out there who think you belong on the
wall alongside bass DJ Khaled and others
I did 10 I'm still here still standing
also I think like you know no one else
has burned their dick on the show so
that's an accomplishment in itself give
them a bronze statue hang it up Eddie
Wong round 2 of hot ones 10 wings up 10
wings down and he still has his feet now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my man this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life I don't even know writing
scripts making movies cash-only coming
to channel near you soon can't wait
Thank You Eddie enjoyed it good to see
you're number one show on the Internet
hot woods he said it not me oh my god
it's always a lot of fun but this who
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you